Jennifer Lopez calls Alex Rodriguez her  superhero  after visiting Puerto Rico I couldn't  have asked for a better partner the  power couple jetted off to Puerto Rico  on Sunday after raising over 25 million  dollars in relief efforts to help  rebuild the country after the recent  devastation from hurricane Maria which  was said to be the worst natural  disaster on record in Puerto Rico  JLo didn't waste any time taking to  Instagram to gush over her giving man  sharing this sweet snap and captioning  the pic in part still many miles to go  but grateful to go the distance side by  side with this amazing guy hashtag he's  my bestie hashtag he's my man hashtag  he's my superhero really excited and a  bit nervous about what we're gonna see  down there the pair was in high spirits  the entire trip snapping pics with the  locals and dancing alongside them in  celebration  this is elevator conversation means  humanity  you